tenemos aquí una gráfica de caja y
bigotes que nos muestra la edad de los
alumnos en una fiesta y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es obtener un poco
de práctica de cómo interpretar estos
diagramas tenemos aquí cinco
afirmaciones y te pido que pongas una
pausa pienses muy bien acerca de estas
afirmaciones y determine cuáles de ellas
son ciertas
cuáles son falsas y para cuáles no
tenemos suficiente información como para
saber si son ciertas o falsas bueno
entonces vamos a empezar con esta
afirmación que nos dice que todos los
estudiantes tienen menos de 17 años
entonces nos fijamos en la gráfica de
caja el 'bigotes' nos fijamos en el
punto máximo que es este el punto
extremo de este bigote el cual se
encuentra en una edad de 16 años así es
que esta afirmación si es verdadera
vamos con la segunda afirmación al menos
75% de los estudiantes tienen 10 años o
más así es que no vamos a ver la gráfica
de caja y bigotes y nos fijamos en este
valor de aquí que es donde empieza el
segundo cuartil aunque bueno tal vez no
queremos escribir esto por aquí
el chiste es que este es el segundo
cuartil y entonces aproximadamente el
25% de los números el 25% de las edades
de los alumnos va a estar en este
cuartil y digo aproximadamente porque no
siempre van a ser exactamente el 25%
pero si es una muy buena aproximación y
también en el tercer cuartel en este
cuartel de aquí van a estar
aproximadamente otro 25% de los datos y
lo mismo pasa con el cuarto cuartil que
hay aproximadamente el 25% de las edades
van a estar en este cuartil así es que
si podemos concluir que al menos 75% de
los estudiantes tienen 10 años o más y
de hecho podría ser que algunos de los
alumnos que tienen 10 años hayan caído
en el primer cuartil pero bueno como
esta afirmación tiene esta parte de alma
y además incluye a todos los que tienen
exactamente 10 años entonces es
verdadera pero sabes que siento que
necesitamos algo más tangible por lo
cual vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos por
aquí
y la verdad es que basándonos en esta
información que es lo único que tenemos
no sabemos cuántos alumnos están en la
fiesta así es que vamos a tener que
construir varios escenarios bueno
tenemos por aquí que la mediana es 13
y podríamos tener un escenario en el que
tenemos justo a un alumno que tiene 13
años y que está justo en la mediana
entonces tenemos por aquí 13 que es la
mediana y digamos que tiene únicamente
tres alumnos a la derecha y tres a la
izquierda
garay este es uno de los posibles
escenarios pero todo esto me lo estoy
inventando nada más estamos tratando de
ver qué podemos averiguar acerca de los
distintos tipos de conjuntos de datos
que son descritos por este diagrama de
caja y brazos así es que el 10
va a estar justo a la mitad de la parte
de abajo aquí va a estar alguien que
tiene 10 años y 15 está justo a la mitad
de la parte de arriba así es que por
aquí hay alguien que tiene 15 años y el
diagrama también nos dice cuál es el
punto mínimo y máximo que nos dice que
el mínimo
7 y el máximo es 16 ahora con respecto a
este número no sabemos nada podría ser
10 podría ser once podría ser 12 o
podría ser 13 y su valor no cambiaría
esta gráfica de caja y bigotes que la
mediana sería la misma y lo mismo para
el mínimo máximo y estos cuartiles
aunque tendríamos exactamente el mismo
diagrama y exactamente lo mismo pasa con
este valor de aquí podría ser 13 podría
ser 14 o podría ser 15 y con todos esos
valores tendríamos el mismo diagrama
pero bueno en este escenario al menos
75% de los estudiantes tienen 10 años o
más pues todos estos estudiantes todos
estos alumnos tienen 10 años o más así
es que tenemos seis de siete que tienen
una edad mayor o igual a diez
y eso es más del 75 por ciento entonces
en este escenario está afirmación si es
verdadera ahora podríamos tratar de
crear otro escenario en donde tratáramos
de reducir la cantidad de personas que
tienen 10 años claro siempre utilizando
la información que nos da este diagrama
digamos por ejemplo que tenemos a 8
alumnos y 8 alumnos
sabemos que el mínimo es 7
sabemos que el máximo es 16 16 y acerca
de la mediana pues ahora tenemos una
cantidad par de alumnos entonces la
mediana está por aquí y va a ser el
promedio de estos dos valores y el
promedio de estos dos valores tiene que
ser 13 y también sabemos que el promedio
entre este y este
es 10 y el promedio entre estos 2
el promedio entre esos dos es 15
entonces con esta información que
escenario podemos construir aunque bueno
para responder esta pregunta no
necesitamos saber estos valores aunque
hay porque este valor va a ser 10 o
mayor y el resto de los valores también
son mayores que vives entonces tenemos
que al menos el 75% de los alumnos tiene
10 o más años y bueno si suponemos que
este valor es distinto de 10 entonces
exactamente el 75% de los alumnos tiene
10 años o más pero bueno aunque no
necesitemos saber cuáles son estos
valores para contestar esta pregunta
para tener un escenario concreto vamos a
poner algunos números por aquí aunque
hay el promedio de estos dos números
tiene que ser 10 si es que digamos que
por ejemplo este número es 9 y entonces
este número tendría que ser
y por aquí pongamos digamos que ponemos
un 12 entonces este número tiene que ser
14 y si ponemos por aquí 14 aquí
tendríamos un 16 pero sabes que mejor
vamos a poner
aquí un 15 y entonces aquí tiene que
haber un 15 si es que podemos estar
bastante convencidos de que al menos el
75% de los estudiantes tienen 10 años o
más ahora qué pasa con la siguiente
afirmación sólo hay un estudiante de 7
años en la fiesta pues veamos el primer
escenario aquí tenemos un solo
estudiante de 7 años y tenemos también
un solo estudiante de 16 años que es la
siguiente afirmación así es que
basándonos en la información que nos da
la gráfica de caja y bigotes si podemos
construir un escenario en el que estas
dos afirmaciones sean verdaderas pero
podemos construir algún otro escenario
que respete la información que nos da
esta gráfica pero en el que estas dos
afirmaciones sean falsas pues resulta
que sí y es justo lo que vamos a hacer
ahorita aunque tenemos por aquí la media
y tenemos 5 alumnos para cada lado 1 2 3
4 5 1 2 3 4 5 la mediana de la mitad de
abajo es 10
10 y la mediana de la mitad de arriba es
15 15 y luego tenemos que el mínimo es 7
y el máximo es 16 pero en cuanto a todos
estos valores tienen muchas opciones
este valor de aquí podría ser 7 o 8 o 9
o 10 y este valor de aquí podría ser 16
o también podría ser 15 pero el chiste
es que si podemos construir basándonos
en esta gráfica podemos construir un
escenario en el que estas afirmaciones
son falsas y bueno si quisiéramos
completar este escenario estos dos
valores podrían ser 10 11 12 o 13 y
estos otros dos valores podrían ser 13
14 o 15 lo importante aquí es que para
cada una de estas dos afirmaciones
tenemos dos escenarios uno en el que
cierta y otro en el que es falsa así es
que no tenemos suficiente información
como para determinar si en él
real estas afirmaciones son verdaderas o
falsas
no sabemos
vemos y lo mismo pasa con esta
afirmación no sabemos
vemos vamos con la siguiente afirmación
exactamente la mitad de los estudiantes
tienen más de 13 años entonces vamos al
primer escenario aquí tenemos a un
alumno con 13 años entonces podría ser
que estos alumnos de aquí tuvieran más
de 13 años pero para empezar no estamos
seguros de qué edad tiene esta persona
podría tener 13 años y además estos
alumnos ya son menos de la mitad así es
que al menos en este escenario la última
afirmación es falsa podemos ahora ir a
ver qué pasa en el segundo escenario por
aquí podemos observar que todos estos
alumnos tienen más de 13 años así es que
al menos en este escenario esta
afirmación es verdadera exactamente la
mitad de los alumnos tienen más de 13
años pero esto no necesariamente tiene
que pasar así
crea un escenario como este con una
cantidad para de alumnos también podría
ser de tal forma que esta afirmación
fuera falsa pero bueno entonces tenemos
un escenario en el que es falsa y un
escenario en el que es verdadera así es
que podemos concluir que con la
información que nos da esta gráfica no
podemos saber si exactamente la mitad de
los alumnos que se fueron a esta fiesta
que es la que nos interesa tienen más de
13 años ok no sabemos
vemos
en fin espero que hayas encontrado muy
interesante este vídeo pero quiero que
sepas que el principal punto de este
vídeo es que cuando te encuentres con
cosas de estadística hay veces en las
que es muy fácil decir ok esto me está
diciendo más o menos esta cosa y muchas
veces esa cosa es correcta pero es muy
importante saber qué tipo de
afirmaciones si podemos hacer y cuáles
otras afirmaciones realmente no podemos
hacer ok es muy importante que cuando
veas algunas estadísticas puedas decir
ok estos datos no me están diciendo que
sucede tal cosa exactamente